in about five seconds so that we may
make a start I'll introduce myself my
name is Danny Kendall I'm chairing
tonight's meeting in accordance with the
rules and regulations to set out on the
inside cover of your agendas tonight
before we get started I could just draw
your attention to a couple of extra
notices if that's okay just to make you
aware of the fact night's meeting is
being recorded and will be available on
the website and on YouTube in the next
day or two should you feel the urge to
relive tonight's fun it's completely up
to you and also if I could ask everybody
really members the public as well to
make sure your phones are set silent or
switched off that'll be handy otherwise
we'll get interrupted at some point it's
always it's usually me but anyway I
think I'm definitely set right so with
those things being said I asked the
people on the top here to introduce
themselves please I'm buying some
committee services make sure those legal
services David Jeffery planning manager
Eddie runs Senior Planner Stewart
philosophy planning officer matt coyne
planning a Senior Planner fantastic
excellent David could I just ask you to
give us a bit more background on upon
your role tonight is that all right of
course thank you my name is David
Jeffrey I'm the planning manager for
tonight's meeting my role is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that arise and to assist members
decision taking I am bound by the Royal
Town Planning Institute's code of
Professional Conduct planning committee
members are not bound by my advice
recommendations fantastic thank you
David Wright okay that's moved to item 1
on tonight's agenda apologies for
absence term apologies from councillor
Perry thank you very much
item 2 disclosure of interests
councillor Jennings for which
application so on application 18 for
stroke zero two zero seven four four
slash ful that's fantastic so heightened
for any other note declarations of
interest
excellent astok moving on to item three
to confirm sign minutes of the meetings
held on the 27th and 29th of May as well
as the 12th of June 2019
do I have your approval thank you okay
and all that stuff out of the way our
first application of the evening this is
item for then and found on page 15 of
your agendas this is application
reference 18 / 0 - 0 7 4 / ful it's for
Henley golf Henry Golf & Country Club
Berman Road Henry an ardent and it's for
the construction of four buildings
containing six apartments each 24 in
total new associated works including
packaged sewage treatment plant and
provision of car parking presenting
officer Eddie wrench ready over to you
Thank You chair
the site as shown by here by the black
dot lies in the open countryside to the
northwest of Henley and Arden adjacent
to the north works a railway line
between Birmingham and
stratford-upon-avon he is also in within
the West Midlands green bow and the
Arden special landscape area the size
accessed off their a3 400 Birmingham
Road to the east along a long private
drive which cost us the railway line
this is an exterior of the site showing
the golf club house to the south an
existing car parking arrangement and the
surrounding environment this is an
indicative overlay of the proposed
development showing the four apartment
buildings and new car parking area it's
also shown nearby are there public
rights-of-way including the proposed
diversion as shown here in orange and a
listed farm health just to the south of
the golf club House has done over there
by the red outline this is a block plan
showing the proposed new bill areas and
landscaping here are the elevations for
blocks 1 & 3 again these are the
elevations for blocks 2 and for all over
very similar size of scale these are
some floor plans for blocks 1 & 3 which
also showed similar floor plans and
arrangements and sizes of apartments to
the other buildings as well going on to
the photo views and this is a view from
the public right-of-way just to the
north of the clubhouse looking back this
is from the public right-of-way which
goes in front of the clubhouse looking
towards where the proposed buildings
would be situated this is from a nearer
to the railway line looking west
approximately two buildings 3 & 4 would
sit this is looking towards the proposed
new car park which would be next to the
railway line which is just beyond the
vegetation at the back
this is from the public right-of-way
which runs across the bridge over the
railway took him back towards the site
as well which was just beyond the
vegetation on the edge this one is
further north along the Arden Way public
right-of-way looking back towards the
proposed development area I've indicated
also the rough approximate site boundary
this finally this is a another one from
the Arden Way public right-of-way
adjacent to the proposed development the
proposed development would be on the
right-hand side that's the existing
vegetarian and also directly ahead
but beyond the vegetation chairman there
are no updates and the recommendation is
to refuse planning permission for the
six reasons detailed on pages 27 and 28
of the agenda thank you all right Thank
You Eddie
okay first speaker for this application
entities accounts the David Broadbent
bodacity and Henry you know the Parish
Council three minutes
if you defeat it at the end for any
questions if I give you a warning at the
last 30 seconds okay over to you right
this committee has recognized the
community value of the Henley Golf &
Country Club as a leisure asset to the
community in approving the planning
application for a 72 bedroom Hotel the
facility employs 30 staff at present
with the potential for more if this
application for 24 departments is
approved whilst the jpc is adamant about
not building in the green belt around
Henley and Beau desert this land is
primarily brownfield with good secular
access off the a3 400 therefore any
argument regarding Greenbelt development
is compromised anyway please note this
committee has already passed the
planning application for the erection of
a 64-bit care home
and 36 assisted-living departments cross
modification to a grade to one listed
building on the southern end of Henle
college with absolutely diabolical
vehicle access off the a3 400 what we're
looking at here is a change of use from
the original planning permission 24 new
homes in the local vicinity is far more
preferable to Henley than a 72 bedroom
hotel he provides additional preceptor
to the community has far more potential
for the occupants to participate in the
community facilities associations and
groups it will benefit the local shops
restaurants and pubs and more sustained
and the excellent well maintained
maintain open aspect of the golf club
but more importantly could free up more
family type homes in the local vicinity
which then invigorates the housing
ladder the Greenbelt policy as required
by corsetry GCS 10 states great weight
should be given to the level of harm to
the Greenbelt in this case the Jaypee
can see no harm whatsoever being caused
to the Greenbelt in fact the additional
planting and screening proposed will
improve the situation in addition the
provision of housing needs for the newly
active retired people within our
district is of great benefit to the
community most of the members of the
golf club are locally based so these
apartments will be particularly
attractive to them regarding affordable
housing this location is totally
unsuitable far better to levy a charge
and use it in the parishes of Henley and
Beau desert
however this committee has to recognize
that small parcels of land within an Lea
and Beau desert need to be allocated for
affordable housing several small parcels
of land owned by the Housing Association
Orbis housing have been noticeably sold
for private housing rather than a full
orbit building affordable housing
affordable housing housing needs to be
built within the community center near
to schools shops and local transport has
been little objection to the community
in the community to this application and
the jpc are fully in favor of this
application and recommend that this
committee approves it thank you do you
have any questions from the committee
no that case counselor thank you very
much raining a large thank you we can
move to our next speaker mr. Peter
Frampton please the agent for the
applicant welcome welcome
the same rules apply so you had three
minutes you'd remain seated thank you
over to you in granting consent for the
72 bedroom hotel in 2009 this Authority
acknowledged that there were very
special circumstances to outweigh the
harm to the Greenbelt for most these
considerations were securing the future
of the business securing existing
on-site jobs and those within the
supporting network of off-site suppliers
the relative sustainability of the site
and its location close to the built-up
area of Henle and in this proposal all
electric vehicles will be provided for
residents to use existing tracks down to
Henley at Bear Lane opportunities to
enhance existing landscaping within the
site and the contribution of you just
heard the of the existing facility to
provide social and recreational life in
Henley and I say these considerations
equally apply to this development the
2009 consent whilst implemented has not
been built out because the viability of
a hotel of this size has moved against
the applicant so rather than providing
much needed revenue into the business
this investment could become a drain on
the resources of the business in
consequence extensive consideration has
been given to other forms of development
that would have a synergy with the Golf
& Country Club the target housing market
is to provide accommodation for active
retired people who seek to downsize an
accommodation from example large houses
with large gardens to a high quality
lifestyle choice housing where they can
opt to play golf use the grounds of the
horse and the facilities of the Country
Club and amenity areas of you just seen
would be maintained by the club this
development is not intended to be
sheltered housing or extra care housing
as the active retired become less active
a subsequent home move would occur to
accommodation that then suited their
domestic needs and that situation I say
is no different to most older people
they will move to their personal as
their personal needs change in
consequence of the form and scale of
apartments where annual service charges
will be levied this accommodation is not
generally suited for affordable housing
hence the suggestion of an off-site
contribution its proposed so that
affordable housing can be targeted to
better locations your councils appointed
viability specialist has concluded that
without further investment which would
be made possible by the proposals there
would be insufficient capital and the
revenue resources to make this loss
making business viable it is entirely
for the judgment of the Planning
Committee to undertake a planning
balance thirty-seconds favor or thank
you of the proposals if members conclude
that the public benefit in turist lies
again in supporting the viability of
this asset to the district then a
planning obligation can ensure that the
enabling financed from the development
is embedded within this business I would
welcome the opportunity to hold these
discussions with your officers and
settle the binding commitment to this
business and I hope members will grant
planning permission for this necessary
development thank you thank you any
questions some liquidity this council
Richards thank you thank you mr.
Frampton it's the intention of golf club
to sell these individually so they will
no longer be any ownership the golf club
once I built
the precise disposal hasn't been
determined what this business needs is
revenue and therefore one of the options
that the club have been looking at is
actually holding the apartment so
they're rented therefore you get an
annual rental income but a few might be
sold to create the capital to undertake
the development but they're all precise
discussions as how that revenue embeds
itself into the business that's the
discussion that I haven't had with your
officers because your officers have
taken the view that the planning balance
is against it
but there's no reason why the revenue or
the finance enabled by this development
cannot embed itself in the business just
like enabling development for heritage
assets Council Jennings how reliant is
the is the golf club on this development
happening versus if it if this
development isn't granted and how many
jobs could be potentially lost well
you've just heard from the parish
counselor that the current business
provides 30 jobs the business has
prating relationships with 12 other
suppliers in the town so the sort of
maintenance and food and things like
that the trajectory of this business is
that it cannot be supported much longer
because it is not a viable as it is
today it is being supported personally
by the owner and that can't continue
much longer I don't have that figure but
it's a trajectory that cannot be
sustained I'm not saying they thought
that later because we have a viability
report which may answer your question
sorry to cut you off sir apologies
counts the Barnes
evening but the hotel building was
permitted closer to the clubhouse than
this proposal because obviously we were
using the clubhouse kitchens to sort of
enable people staying in the hotel to be
much closer to the the center of the
golf course facilities but as you saw in
the photographs this this development is
further fear and I think there's some
measurements yeah it's on the developed
space of the golf course the tenant old
tennis courts and the car parking area
okay there are no further questions mr.
Proctor thank you very much Thank You
children
of course our Ward members not that
we're speaking on this one so points of
clarification
councillor Richards just following on
from councillor Barnes is pointing there
can you indicate on the plan exactly
where the 70-200
bedroom hotel so this was the approved
hotel this is the existing clubhouse was
basically an extension it was gonna be
linked and then wrap around the front of
the building so the siting of it is is
very much different as mr. Franzen said
yeah this was much closer association
with the golf club and and it was more
of an extension to that facility rather
than new built to them to the north or
did you have a bigger map that will show
it in relation to the theater this was
2009 of which this was the best perhaps
you can indicate on the Google
yeah if we go back to the one of them so
if we were looking here the link for the
hotel would come in here then it's
almost this area just around where
there's like a small car part to the
front it would be wrapped into this area
demonstrable our Jose what's been
proposed in what we were looking at
before what has been approved it's
lieutenant the repo tower is smaller yes
and it's obviously got closer connection
with that building so it's got tighter
points of clarification cap so Jennings
you want to ask your question I think it
has work X did work actually start on
the hotel it has been implemented some
of it I don't quite know how to be
implemented but it has technically so
it's still extant but there's no work
physically as in there's no part of the
hotel that's standing okay sorry so with
the preet with the hotel of it clearly
there was a link physical link to it but
also the revenue from the hotel was
linked to the golf club and it's clear
it's quite direct i'm that obviously
weighed in the minds of the decision
maker at the time with this proposal
there's no indication as to how their
links and whereas we've heard that it's
not clear from the agent as to exactly
how they're linked is that right was
that thought through or brought out when
the consultants had a look at the
viability in terms of how the viability
of assessed herbs purely as a as a
revenue stream
I think Peter Peter mentioned before it
purely as just providing money to feed
into the business rather than any sort
of link in terms of people staying or
using the facilities or any sort of
thing like that it's purely just to
provide money into the business was how
it was assessed so what I'm trying to
get from that
is there any identification as to the
length of time that that is likely to go
into the business from from my
understanding and this might be
completely wrong so that's why I want to
clarity if one were to sell those it's a
one-off capital receipt not a revenue
receipt if one were to rent them it
would be a revenue C and would be
ongoing but we've got no indication as
to which one that is no there's been no
indication from the applicant in terms
of how it was going to be distributed I
think it was our assumption that they'd
all be sold but who ever receive any
information otherwise counts the buyers
you indicated that tool across my
thoughts earlier this development
he's on parted what's already had
planning permissions accurate no it's on
differently sighted so it's further to
the north legal like with the hotel
obviously it would be one business these
houses are they going to be incorporated
in the business or is it a separate
venture we haven't got any details of
that if they would be owned in the first
instance by the owners of the golf
course and then they could obviously
sell it rent it or do whatever they want
but there's no physical link as in the
hotel obviously there's a link between
the users okay council atom cross cat
sticks Thank You chair just to clarify
there was a point that I believe
councillor Broadbent and parish council
raised that suggesting it wasn't
concerned for Greenbelt and it may be a
brownfield site could use clarifying
that please yes certainly
I mean purely in Greenbelt terms there
is an allowance for development of
previously developed land where it
doesn't have a greater impact on the
openness of the Greenbelt so the
existing uses for car park so that has a
certain amount of use in terms of visual
and height and permanence of the
vehicles on that this would obviously
have a far far greater impact in terms
of openness
the any existing previously developed
use it also is an all previously develop
use it as you can sort of see here it
would go into some undeveloped areas so
just pure greenfield site as well so all
in all as I think it's acknowledged by
the applicant as well it is
inappropriate development which would
have a greater impact on openness
councillor Dixon Thank You chairman my
understanding from what mr. Frampton was
saying was that he hasn't had an
opportunity to discuss finances
now obviously linking the development
and the revenue stream is an essential
element that was part of the hotel it's
not yet part of this one is it feasible
and is it possible from your perspective
that if we were to grant permission this
evening that conditions can be placed to
ensure that a revenue stream from such a
development does come into the hotel on
a sustainable basis ie if you sell if
you sell some of them to fund it and
rents the rest can they actually link
that income stream on a sustainable long
term basis condition boards seem
unreasonable to me because you're
stepping into property law but of course
this is planning law I think what the
applicant is saying is basically that
the council will get its playing
obligation by the housing contribution
but basically any money that it makes
from the stream will will go basically
directly to the company it's not really
the District Council's interest to get
involved in that but that's more of a
property issue than planning issue and I
think the and economic condition
confirming that would be unreasonable
Dave
Thank You chair and just to sort of set
this in a bit of a framework what
members will have seen from the
committee report is the officers
position is that to be acceptable in
greenbelt terms members would have to be
satisfied that very special
circumstances existed that overcame all
the harm to the Greenbelt and any other
harm cumulatively the reason officers
haven't proceeded to go into the mine
UTI of how revenue flows may be
distributed out to this development is
that there is an in principle objection
to the proposal is it's outside the
built-up area boundary and on the basis
of the plans before us officers can't
see how this is acceptable in terms of
impact on openness and so it wasn't
necessary for us to to go into that
detail at this stage because we don't
see how very special circumstances could
exist for this level of development
makeup artists just thinking there's
also one point about trying to actually
manage such a condition as well and you
know you put an extra burden on officers
to assess the accounts from the company
which I mean viability it has been done
before but this is a little bit
different to the norm so yeah right any
other points clarification from the
committee should we open up for debate
who would like to start Council bonds
big mass in the greenbelt
is it special is it needed sort of but
not I didn't know the golf he's had a
great decline because we've had a lot of
applications for improvements to golf
courses and benches to diversification
everybody's riding their bike
well not everybody but that's the key
picked by a month I barely feel smaller
I could go along with it but at the
moment now I'll go along with the
reserve recommend unfortunately Thank
You counsel and counsel Richards Thank
You chair there are a lot of reasons for
the refusal sout and the office report
I'm gonna focus primarily on the the
green belt ones as chance would happen
there is a similar arrangement Golf Club
in my ward which is also watched over by
green belt they also as many golf clubs
are the moment struggle financially will
have been struggling financially they
have installed a hotel we approved it
from Jim Smith five years ago now and
their business has come on leaps and
bounds have been hugely successful and I
see no reason why the same couldn't
happen here with the existing permission
we've already seen that existing
permission is significantly smaller in
scale than what we're looking at here so
therefore would have them at this would
have a materially larger impact on the
green belt and I see no special
circumstances at all that would link
this directly to the hotel if the if it
was clear as in I hope as in it would be
with the hotel with a revenue stream and
an ongoing revenue stream I'd be a
little bit more amenable to it but the
only way I can see this happening is
one-off capital receipts we then have to
rely on the management of the golf tub
and I'm sure they'd be more than capable
of doing it but we can't guarantee that
and if the Golf Club then fails we still
have this huge development that has had
the significant impact on the openness
of that area so with that in mind and
notwithstanding the other reasons I will
proposing that we go there was a
recommendation refused and set out in in
our reports thank you really I would
like to speak on this I'll add my
thoughts which you've said it better
than me and I think a completely agree
with you this is just far far too big
and there's no guarantee at all that it
will help the golf club and I have great
sympathy for a struggling business like
this but when we're talking about
development as large as this one in the
in the green belt well I'm afraid I
can't possibly support it so I'm happy
to second counselor just proposed
proposal does anybody else want to speak
on this before we go to a vote do you
propose I didn't hear that we've got
we've got a proposal and second if
you're content so that's thank you okay
the proposition is to refuse all those
in favor please show six chairs against
one channel all right there's no
extensions so they commuted there for
results to refuse occasion reference 18
slashes zero two zero seven four slash
ful can move
[Music]
okay let's move on to our next item is
item five thank you on page 33 of your
agendas so this is application reference
19 slash 0 1 0 to 5 slash ful and this
is site addressed on roaming stables
Gospel Oak Lane path low
stratford-upon-avon is for the planning
application for second mobile home and
shared utility block with associated
hard standing on gypsy traveller site
presenting officer sorry I'm moving a
bit quick here it's to apply T here to
go through over to you them Thank You
chairman good evening miss proposal
seeking full Planning Commission for a
second mobile home associative heart
standing and a shared utility block on
an exist and on an existing gypsy
traveller site this application area is
in their open countryside outside of the
built-up area boundary of path flow west
of the a3 400 and to the north of Gospel
Oak Lane as indicated by this black dots
on the plan here we see the application
site outlined in red this site is washed
over by the green belts in addition to
being within the Arden special landscape
area here we see a satellite image of
the application site signified by the
red arrow here we have the existing site
layout plan detailing the existing
mobile home station on site here
what can all see the stables to the
South section of the site here and a
touring Caravan which is indicated here
there is also than paddock land
indicated here here we now see a
proposed site layout plan with the
second mobile home proposed to be sited
here one can also see a shared utility
block which is proposed to be stationed
here and a second touring caravan now
this involves bringing a torrent cavern
on sites that close here and a slight
reciting of the current one protocol at
the previous slide which is there just
moving that to here basically here we
have a indicative elevation of the
utility block as proposed we now have
some photos of the site and its
surroundings
here we are stood on the existing mobile
home site looking Northwest woods
towards the current mobile home and the
burning road over the existing boundary
you can see here the 8th of 3 400 here
we are stood in the same position now
looking southeast woods in the direction
of Gospel Oak Lane one can see that
there is a turn Caravan Korean Institute
in addition to the vehicle access to the
site here here we are now looking
southwards of existing stables and again
part of the vehicle access that you can
see as a previous photo here we are now
stood in the designated paddock area
it's a north of existing mobile home
looking southwards one can see here the
presence of some domestic paraphernalia
here we're now stood in the same
position looking southeast woods down
the site one can see a touring caravan
at the bottom here one can also see
presence of some building materials and
further domestic paraphernalia here and
then the boundary treatment consisting
of clothes board fencing mature trees
hedgerow on the boundary fronting Gospel
Oak Lane
and here we stood now back on the
existing mobile home sites looking where
the proposed second mobile Hope mobile
sites would be posted there's also you
can see a presence of a horse currently
on the paddock land here we're now stood
on Gospel Oak Glen itself along the
south eastern boundary of the site one
could see in further detail here the
existing boundary treatments of fronting
on the road and also looking downwards
towards the junction towards the a3 400
finally here is a small excerpt of
capsules gypsy and traveler
accommodation assessments the GT
d'herblay update study now this is dated
from April 2019 this is an
evidence-based document which was
approved by cabinets on the 3rd of June
2019 and this is very much a material
consideration in the assessment of this
application as detail on page 42 of your
agenda packs this assessment identifies
the need for district to provide 59
additional pictures for the period of
twenty nine twenty thirty five as an
obligation
with an additional eleven pictures as
diesel here as a potential need in the
area of freudian total figure of 70 of
these twenty-eight detailed here need to
be provided in the first five years of
the 2024 in summary as detailed the
conclusion on page 43 of your agenda
pack this is a very this is defined as
inappropriate development in the green
belt where very special circumstances
need to be demonstrated outweigh this
harm
it is officers view that v8 farad
special circumstances have been
demonstrated but one considers the
personal needs and circumstances of the
family the lack of a five year supply of
sites and lack of availability of
alternative sites and a very recently
endorsed evidence-based document
detailing the needs and obligation to
provide a minimum of 59 pictures within
the district and within this report
finally there is also a clear directive
and preference for the intensification
of existing sites in addition to
additional vehicle creation of new sites
I'd like to refer you to the update
sheets for this evening whereupon there
are three additional suggested
conditions detailed based on a recent
officer site visits Chairman the
recommendation is to grant this
application for the reason set up pages
41 to 44 of your agendas thank you Thank
You Stuart
okay so our first spate the speaker on
this application councillor Kate
Sherlock for a moment the wind code
parish council please welcome councillor
so you also have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end and I'll give you a warning at 30
seconds if that's okay you want to press
the button in the middle of the
microphone so the light comes on you can
speak in - thank you right
the government's 2015 publication
planning policy for traveler sites
states that thun making and decision
taking should protect the Greenbelt from
inappropriate development and policy e
makes clear that traveler sites in the
Greenbelt are inappropriate development
and should not be approved except in
very special circumstances paragraphs 1
for 3 and 1 for 4 at the NPP F stated in
appropriate development is by definition
harmful to the Greenbelt and very
special circumstances will not exist
unless the potential harm to the
Greenbelt is clearly outweighed by other
considerations will cut Parish Council
argues that no very special
circumstances exist the NPP F and P BTS
make clear that subject to the best
interests of the child personal
circumstances and unmet need are
unlikely to clearly outweigh harm to the
Greenbelt so as to establish very
special circumstances paragraph 27 if
the ppts says that where a local
authority cannot demonstrate an
up-to-date five-year supply of
deliverable sites this should be a
significant material consideration when
considering applications for grants
except in certain circumstances one of
which is where the proposal please in
the green belt paragraph 10 D of the
ppts states that planning authority
should relate the number of pictures or
plots to the circumstances of the
specific size and location of the site
and the surrounding population size and
density the addition of a second picture
now ancillary buildings is
overdevelopment of this
right and is detrimental to the openness
of the Greenbelt there's a high
concentration of travelers compared to
the settle community in Palo a second
pitch on the done roaming site will
exacerbate this the application does not
conform with long Kepner bur hood plan
specifically WP 10 development in Palo
nor does it confirm with conform with
the core strategy CS 10 12 and 21
when permission was granted for one
pitch in 2017 occupation was restricted
to mr. mrs. fury and their resident
dependents will perish council supported
that application which relied heavily on
the welfare of the children who were in
full-time education locally providing
the very special circumstances the
current application for a second pitch
for their daughter states that she has
need for her own living space the
applicants daughter is no longer in
full-time education is in work and
therefore cannot be considered dependent
on her parents the applicants are in no
different situation to the settled
community who would like to provide
accommodation for a growing family but
face restrictions on building in the
Greenbelt a recent post by mrs. fury on
the site next door will exceed 30
seconds for her daughter's wedding
february 20 2016 up her own from the
unit further evidence of lack of
dependency granting this applications
there's a precedent for this site and
others to increase pictures as children
reach independence in summation no
special circumstances required by
planning policy exist and the
application should not therefore be
granted Thank You counsel
any questions councillor Richards thank
you very much that you obviously wanted
to get a lot of points into you spoke
quite quickly I miss and I did and I
have brought a brief summary of the
major points with your I can't we can't
even thank you anyway but well I can add
some questions though there was a lot of
earlier on in your speech he talks about
I think something DTS he said reasons
why we can't rely on our lack of
five-year on the planning policy for
traveler sites
2015 Franklin which was from the
government and local communities
Department
that's what I wanted thank you very much
any other questions
cuts the bones am I correct in saying
you approved the one will cut polish
councils history on the societies that
have been three applications and will
parish council I understand there wasn't
counselor then opposed the first two
applications which were given three-year
temporary ones and then in 2017 there
was an application for a permanent one
pitch and we'll put parish council
supported that because there was
evidence that the children were
attending the primary schooling will
code one more question for me you
mentioned this is in via or against the
I think he said something development
impact low was that a parish platform
there is a neighborhood plan
neighborhood plan and that's fully
adopted by district council yes thank
you right any other questions from the
committee that case cats of Sherlock
thank you very much for your time
tonight okay we can go then to our next
speaker Hughie fury the applicant please
welcome same rules apply thing it's
still switched on so just that's okay
that's fine you got three minutes if you
remain seated for any questions at the
end over to you well don't expect the
speech like that was not as well
educated it's for me it's not a second
pitch obviously there's a mobile I'm
going on there it's an extension for the
same family which was granted permission
in 2017 s just for my daughter regards
to getting married that's news to me
I hope she empties a 17 in fact she
tells me that she wants to step out of
the gypsy box own and become independent
get a job on her own obviously but you
need somewhere to live at the moment
she's sharing a bedroom and a small
mobile home with a 15 yard brother which
is not really nice for her or him most
of time he sleeps on the sofa so that's
the reason for his wanting the second
pitch in regards to green belt obviously
I'm a planner anything but it's one
mobile home as you can see a long way is
into the neighboring paddock by six
meters it's not like a big application
site for another family as for the same
time you've already got permission and
also us in the small hamlet of where the
car sales people are actually we're just
on the corner it's not out of place it's
very well screened that's really all I
can say about it thank you - any
questions for counsel riches thank you
for that in our papers we've got a
reference to a previous application that
was withdrawn it's basically the same
thing you're looking for is there any
particular reason why it was withdrawn
are they completely unrelated well no it
was I think the mobile home was the
upper box inside the fence I was just
thinking a bit more space probably for
meself and the offers at the time
officers at time said it was probably
gone too far into the paddock so could
we bring up another plan which brings it
more into the existing site so it's
literally mobile home on the edge of the
the hard standing so we don't have to
make too much more outstanding so just
making a smallest get a thing of it
rather than doing it to the ballot so
from that I'm taking you've had an
active conversation with our offices to
try and find a mineral solution well I
think my planner planner did and she
relayed the message in media yes cancer
Jennings so just a clarification
how many people are on this I know for
of years it as me my wife and four kids
my son's like young me up the oldest
ones 15 the rest for me younger kids in
school and as my daughter which is 17
this six in total six and oh okay they
cancel bonds
am i right then he withdrew the last
application they go along with
restarting in the respect of the no no I
think I think would probably sound and
it was in consultation with the officers
so I think that was the reason it was we
perhaps come back to that later on if
that's okay there are no other questions
mr. fury thank you very much for your
time thank you okay we'll go to our ward
member counselor Shenton
we've canceled Shenton welcome okay so
you you have five minutes
I suppose you know the routine but if
you decide if any questions at the end
over to you a problem any fate of many
of us face when families start to grow
up and eventually look to set up their
own residence for the partners we or the
family gets bigger is that we try and
extend our own house or we create
another residence within our own
boundaries or do we buy another one in
another location the applicant has my
sympathy because as I say it's the
dynamic that many of us face including
myself but as highlighted in the report
which self quoting a government report
and I quote unmet need whether for
traveler sites or for conventional
housing is unlikely to outweigh harm to
the Greenbelt and other harm to
constitute the very special
circumstances the report seems to assert
that the unmet need is greater than the
harm however if the choice is to create
another residence within our boundaries
as what seem to be the case here various
guidelines have to be followed and the
application seeks to establish another
residential unit at the expense of the
green bell those policies be in the NDP
the MPP F the core strategy and DG taa
in none of the above documents does it
say that we should ignore the protection
of the green belt in addition if we're
to encourage parishes to create their
own NDP and empower communities to take
more control over development that we
must be consistent and we must trust the
local council otherwise what I have an
NDP let's see at this point what we
actually do agree on in the report in
the green belt it falls in the ardent
special landscape area it's an open
countryside the NDP core strategy in the
MPP F resist development in the
Greenbelt except in certain cases in the
NDP policy WP 10 deals specifically with
development in Parsloe and says that any
proposal will only be supported if it
limits
into the open countryside and this is
definite incursion we agree on many of
the core strategy policies but the
interpretation between the report and
ourselves may be different in cs10
greenbelts say the CST policy cs10 about
the green belt states that any
development is deemed inappropriate
unless it does not result in
disproportionate additions over and
above the size of the original buildings
which entry via the rule of thumb being
used as a guide of 40% this is above
that a key part of policy CS 12 on
special landscapes that is not
highlighted in the report says on an
individual basis some proposals may seem
innocuous but cumulatively they could
form part of a general decline in the
quality of the landscape policy CS 21
gypsy and travelers and traveling show
people says you it will be considered
events various criteria and at the top
of that is paraphrasing here the site
should not be located within the
Greenbelt unless there are very special
circumstances in section five point
seven point three map one shows the
preferred sites this is not in either of
those two areas five point seven point
four in relation to proposed sites and
the Greenbelt each stage there must be
in accordance with the MPP F and very
special special circumstances will not
exist
unless the potential harm to the
Greenbelt by reason of inappropriateness
and any other harm is clearly outweighed
by the considerations section 13 talks
about protecting the Greenbelt and lists
the exceptions this application doesn't
fall in those exceptions so again I'd
reiterate the unmet need is unlikely to
outweigh harm as you can see in the
report in my comments we broadly agreed
the green belts a special landscape
policies do not see to mitigate the
resistance of development and in these
areas within the GTA a accepted by the
Cabinet it was suggested that there is a
need to locate any new accommodation
away from the parcel and we are
two areas if this was not seafood
significant it would not have been
included in the report so to recap the
Parish Council decision and the reasons
for parrot refused love this application
are supported by the NDP the core
strategy the MPP F and the G taa also
appears to support the view unmet need
is also unlikely to be considered a very
special reason a growing family is not I
would argue a special circumstances
whether it is because they're growing up
or growing away and it does no wait
we're way the harm done to the
additional development in the green belt
this is a problem faced by many families
that we would not generally allow any
resident to build or extend within the
green belt on unmet needs alone
it would appear that the recommendation
is driven by the desire to achieve the
five year supply target as much as made
of this in the report the whole subject
of whether the family's house he needs
30 seconds has not been accepted
universally in other applications in my
opinion this was set up and on welcome
precedent and mean the various policies
would need to be reviewed I ask you to
refuse this application on the grounds
that highlighted in that it fails every
test on green belt special landscape
very special circumstances and the GTAA
itself thank you you must have practiced
that any questions for the ward member
please from the committee
go on counsel Richard thank you thank
you very much Jensen I think you
probably agree with me if I said that
this is a blank site then absolutely the
what you've just put forward as screen
belt issues would apply but I think you
probably also agree that because it's
already been cited here as a judge in
traveler area and has been for over
eight years that that precedent has
already been set on the site would you
how would you respond to that first of
all
I would agree that there was a precedent
set in that a unit was allowed on the
site I would suggest that in the MPP F
it actually the state if you like that
just because it's been the there is a
building there doesn't mean that you can
add another building we tend to say I'm
that the equal the the rules were Slayer
in actual fact to be applied equally to
built up houses as well as for the
traveling community and this exceeds
those rules simply thank you if this
were a house on that site and someone
we're seeking to expand it would you
apply the same rules that prevent them
from being expand at home according to
MPs expanding your home I'm sorry it's a
bit of a hypothetical and we've got to
stick to what we've got before us we I'm
not sure it's relevant I'm afraid so
I've coming out to stop you on that one
because you're dealing with a
hypothetical planning application there
and that's not one before us I'm sorry
any other questions so gently enjoy
moving towards I should I suppose I
should have asked this before to the
parish and I'm presuming that they
wouldn't have supported two mobile sites
mobile homes on this site a few years
ago when they I'm sorry I think we're
again we're dealing with hypotheticals I
think we can we can go around this as
much as we like it but what would you
approve or what you wouldn't you approve
it we've got to stick to the application
all right in that case Cancer Council
Shenton thank you very much right points
of clarification maybe this can help
what do we think any questions yes
now Richard said move around thank you
so cancer Sherlock talks about the PPE
TS as its counselor Shenton just now
you've you've touched on it briefly in
the report but the specifics that
they're talking about the green belt and
whether one should use a lack of
available sites or a lack of five-year
supply has been appropriate as a BSc a
very special circumstance can you expand
on that for us and why I'm not reading
any of that in the report if I might
have missed it but yeah the report only
does touch on the PPS page 37 and what
you've heard is correct the ppts that
set out that it's unlikely that we're
not withstanding the best interest of
the child unmet need is on its own
likely to overcome greenbelt harm I
think you touched on it yourself in your
questions this is an existing site we
have to look at what harm arises to the
green belt by the proposals we concluded
that there clearly is harm to the
openness of the green belt as officers
it's a matter of planning judgment to
determine a level of harm that is the
guidance in the NPP F and the PPTs is
clear that there is a judgment to be
made in terms of very special
circumstances and a threshold to be
passed
officers view was that with the
information available in respect of the
special circumstances of the applicant
and the evidence base that's emerging in
respect of the need for gypsy traveller
pitches that those two things together
in this circumstance on an existing site
as unlikely as it may be was felt to
overcome the base the threshold the very
special circumstances and that's where
we
recommendation I mean I understand what
you're saying I'm not I'm not entirely
clear that answer the question I was
looking for maybe I didn't phrase it
with my question right
we were we were told by both counts of
Sherlock and council Shenton that the
PPTs clearly shows that a very special
circumstance is not a lack of a
five-year supply in this instance
whereas from what I'm reading and
forgive me if I'm reading this
incorrectly but we're using that lack of
supply and the need for further pictures
as a very special circumstance have I
completely misunderstood that only
insofar as it says that it's unlikely it
doesn't say it's impossible or so it's
unlikely to be a very understands but
it's unlikely to be political and your
what you're doing here is considering
the fact that it's already a gypsy
traveller pitch therefore that can weigh
on that very special circumstance I
think that that is relevant yes that's
made it clear Thank You councillor Dixon
thank council band Thank You chairman I
know that the permission that was
granted in this site was specific to the
family I've not seen any conditions on
this application which would prevent the
site from subsequently being split is it
possible to put on such a condition if
we are minded to approve it because a
situation where by looking at those
photographs looking at that plan the
Parish Council has suggested that a
second round was over development I
would not support that opinion and I
thought that site is being very open and
not open by way of site because I must
admit I've been driving past that for
the last 20 odd years and even didn't
even know it but so it's not been there
for 20 years but I've been driving past
that on a fairly regular basis and I
didn't even know it was there until I
saw this application so it is a very
well screened site
basically can socially conditioned it
that it cannot to be split inspectors
certainly have found that personal
permissions for gypsy and traveler sites
can be appropriate and meet the tests
they have not been forwarded as part of
our recommendation in this circumstance
because the advice in the practice
guidance is that they should only when
the very exceptional circumstances be
used restricting a site to a certain
type or demographic of user is
appropriate and so what we were Pro
proposed as our recommendation is that
it be restricted to only people from a
gypsy traveller background what members
do have it within their gift to alter
that recommendation if they see fit to
do so and feel that a personal punishing
is more appropriate but they would have
to be satisfied that this is an
exceptional circumstance sufficient to
allow that okay I'm just going to ask
master to comment on that as well from a
legal perspective what is that to stop
us doing that do you comfortable as well
you sure excuse me yes I'm happy with it
okay we'll come back to the point later
maybe we'll come back to it later in the
debate councillor Barnes just clarifying
that if we were to approve it it is a
named person
that's not offices current
recommendation my deputies as at the
moment the recommendation is that they
should be gypsies accommodation on the
site and for no other purposes but it is
within members gift if you like to
reconsider that condition and make it a
personal permission the named person if
they feel there are exceptional
circumstances that justify that it would
still count as a gypsy traveller site
though it would okay okay all right any
other questions points clarification on
anything else which we go to the debate
open let's cancel Dixon Bing counsel
Richards if that's all right yes
principle of gypsy sites within the
Greenbelt has been established and if we
were to now basically say that we're not
permitting a second home in respect of
that one family then I think we would be
on a a very difficult situation to try
and sustain that against any future
action the site is well screened and I
do not regard it as over development to
put one more vamp on there and therefore
I would be supportive of the officers
recommendation would you be seeking to
apply the additional condition that we
mentioned earlier so there will be a
named and permission indeed so they
couldn't subsequently sell off half of
the plot to another traveling family
admittedly but what I'll do is I'll ask
chaps if you want how to think about
wording of that condition for us so we
can come back to it in a minute capsule
Richard thank you I think
Castle diction actually is very
concisely and eloquently made the point
that I was trying to get to when
in councilor Shenton but not doing very
good job of so I in same vein the
principle of elements already set in
terms of gypsies and travellers there's
no reason why we shouldn't allow some
expansion on that side we if we were
looking at home there's policy to allow
the expansion of a home why would we
restrict that in terms of the gypsies
and drivers I think that's the point I
was trying to make so I'm entirely
comfortable with it I just want clarity
on this condition are we naming an
individual that will live in that pitch
or mobile home or are we saying the
entire site is for the use of the named
family and what impact could that have
if this were to change if the site were
to change hands in the future would it
mean this this building has been unbound
or how does that work David
previous permissions on the site have
stipulated that the occupation of the
site be permitted and restricted to mr.
Hughie fury mrs. Melissa fury and their
resident dependents I think that it
would be reasonable and necessary for
officers to ensure that that would be
effective in this circumstance and so
what I would propose if members were
minded to resolve that that's the type
of condition that they want that they
therefore delegate it to officers to
conclude on the final wording of the
named residents and that that be agreed
by officers in consultation with the
chair of committee before issuing any
permission another basis that that's the
existing condition I see no reason why
we shouldn't expand on it so I'm
comfortable that and I'll second the
proposal thank you it was proposed by
councillor Dixon seconded by Councillor
riches councillor Jennings I just had a
question about the users notion there
about the dependent but presumably when
they reached the age of 18 then no
longer dependent as I'm alright tonight
assumption
under certain actually can still be
dependents up to a very old age so it's
a tricky one I'm afraid
I'm shooting it round it's by I think
that's what we mean when we say precise
wording to go to the officers and that
will come if it'll come back to me it
says that all right I think I've got a
very good understanding of what you're
all trying to go along with so I'll look
at the wording very carefully when it
comes back in yeah councillor balance my
birth parish councils and myself work
together with the gypsies when there
were three more but we do have their
system of knowing who's on there and all
related you could probably use that
condition into account as well right we
have a proposition and it's been
seconded well of course I should say
with the updated condition as we've all
mentioned already which we confirm the
precise wording will be confirmed and
the additional conditions that you've
found on your update sheet tonight
everybody so cancer Dixon you're happy
with that I'm just checking you you've
seen the additional conditions on the
update right that case we go to the vote
the proposition is to grant all those in
favor please show thank you therefore
the committee resolves to grant
application reference 19 / 0 1 0 2 5 /
ful we'll go to our next item final item
of the evening item 6 just give a few
seconds people to move around of it
okay let's go to item six some page 47
of your agendas and his application
reference 19 / 0 1 2 1 / ful and it's
for the land adjacent to 18 Norton's
closed bonfire hill North End and it's
for the full application for the
erection of a single detached dwelling
which is part retrospective presenting
officer Matthew Quinn
yes thank you chairman yes so the
application site relates to land
adjacent at 18 Norton as close as in the
the local service village of North End
the site itself is positioned at the
southeastern edge of the village as
indicated by the black dog listen to
this ring there
North End itself is a category for local
service village situated to the east the
m-40 motorway and northwest at Burton
dassit Country Park just to the south
east of the application site so the red
line here shows the the application I'm
sorry and the landers part this
application including the upgraded
access to the north the proposals yes so
they also include that that access there
is a public footpath that runs outside
of but close to the south western
boundary the site indicated sort of by
the green dashed line there there's
considerable changes in the levels
across the site so it goes uphill to the
South quite considerably the sliders and
contain a listed buildings it's not in a
conservation area but it is in the on
stones Hill special landscape area this
is a scenario view of this site so
you've got burned asset Country Park
down here this is the settlement of
North End the application site just
where the cursor is there this is
Norton's clothes leading up to the the
road here and just a closer view aerial
view of the site you can see that the
slab base and retaining wall have gone
in in that in that view so that that's
the part retrospective element of the
scheme
these are these building
here agricultural buildings so the land
itself is agricultural surrounded by
agricultural fields this view here is
looking towards mr. Norton's clothes
sorry from the edge of the site so this
is Norton's clothes here leading back
towards the main road up at the end got
two photos here one on the left hand
side looking towards the junction with
more house lane and pear trees and then
the other is looking back uphill towards
the site so the tarmac sort of edge of
the road ends here and then it turns
into track going uphill to the country
park the sites just on the right-hand
side sort of free that cap their sisters
looking from within the agricultural
land to the southeast looking back down
towards the property so you can see that
it's been started to be built found this
is the side elevation of eighteen
norton's close they've got a
single-story element that finishes just
sort of behind where that tree is there
again another one looking from the
agricultural land back down across the
the property that the new access is
going in just sort of in that gap a
vegetation there this is the proposed
block plan so it shows two car parking
spaces and a visitor space there's also
a gated access which continues the use
of into the agricultural field beyond
you've got two projection Gables one at
the front one at the rear and a
projecting gabled dormer and you can see
the retaining wall just around the the
eastern part of the site just ER
so it's a three-bedroom property and
these are just the floor plans that show
that and then the elevation so this is
the the front elevation on the top left
of your screen the rear elevation in the
bottom left the side elevation which
front 18 norton's closes the bottom
right image okay so there's a detailed
assessment in the application and that's
included in your agenda pack starting on
page 47 in summary the lawful use of
this site is in agriculture and the site
is surrounded by open countryside on
three sides as such the site is
considered to be outside the physical
confines of the settlement in this
regard the principle of development in
offices opinion is not considered to be
acceptable and would be contrary to the
policies in the core strategy it is
noted that there is an earlier outline
application which was granted on appeal
during which the inspector gave
considerable weight to the lack of a
five-year housing land supply this
permission is now lapse the council
can't Deborah demonstrated five-year
housing land supply and we've got
adopted core strategy policies the
proposed design of the dwelling in my
view is on balance acceptable and for
the reasons set out in my report the
proposed development is not considered
to result in any harm to the residential
immunity highway safety or equality
thank you thank you okay let's go to our
first speaker counsel James Gordon
coming please from burdened asset Parish
Council
welcome counselor so same as before you
have three minutes if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end I'll
give you a warning at 30 seconds if
that's okay
go get to you this is an unfortunate
situation we the parrot council finds
ourselves in we are keen to enable
people with family ties to our community
to return to or remain within our parish
what we cannot be seen to do however is
to allow development under these
circumstances that we would not allow if
the application had come from an
individual with no local links that
would be a Pandora's box I have no wish
to be responsible for opening nor should
my esteemed planning officers the
original proposal for which outline
planning was granted was significantly
smaller better aligned front and back
with the neighboring property and was of
a t-shape with the largest and highest
section being farthest from the neighbor
the new proposal has squared this T
shape meaning there is no attempt to
present a lower profile to the boundary
with the neighbor the whole building is
two-story whereas the original was a
single-story on the element of the
building closest to the neighboring
property and critically the entire
building has been moved by more than two
metres towards the rear of the plot in
order to provide parking spaces at the
front because the integral garage in the
original proposal has now been lost in
favor of increased living space the
two-story rear now extends beyond the
single-story rear of 18 Norton's close
and well over four metres beyond the
two-story part of eighteen Norton's
closed while falling short of the 45
degree test the new building will have a
detrimental impact on the early morning
light to the rear windows of 18 Norton's
close had this proposal come before the
parish council for detailed planning
permission it would have been refused
and therefore we have no option but to
refuse the application in retrospect I
find it difficult to understand how
Sheldon bows lead in question at any
stage whether it
had not gone through detailed planning
one would assume the advantage of
commissioning the professionals is I
think that mistakes like this are not
made to conclude the Parish Council most
firmly insists this application be
refused affirming the absolute
requirement for all applications to
follow to process whatever the personal
circumstances thank you thank you any
questions for the parish council nope
okay it's cut off lightly thank you very
much all right
we now if the applicant mr. Matthew
Hayden and agent and Tasha Blackmore
DaSilva please good evening so welcome
both you have three minutes between you
how do how do you want to split that up
I'll be speaking but any questions
wonderful thank you that case over to
you could I just have a 30 second thank
you okay so good evening I am here on
behalf of my client to speak in support
of this I am here on behalf of my client
to speak in support of full application
for the erection of a new dwelling part
retrospective
I thank officers for their constructive
feedback and assistance to date and for
permitting us to set out our case on the
committee this evening as a quick
summary outlined consent for a drowning
was approved at appeal on this plot in
2014 and indicative site plan
illustrating the approximate footprint
was also submitted at that time after
consent was granted a discharge of
conditions application was submitted at
this point the reserved matters plans
for the dwelling were incorrectly
submitted under condition one which
requested reserved matters details be
submitted and approved to the council
prior to commencement these plans were
validated as part of the submission and
once an approval for the application was
received the applicant commenced works
on the site's Building Control signed
off the installation of the approved
drainage scheme footings and concrete as
a commencement and the applicant
continued to work works to build his
home the applicant has proceeded in good
safe this
not a case of a conscious breach of
planning control or an attempt to bypass
the rules a genuine mistake was made and
the applicants have proceeded in the
belief and understanding that they had
fulfilled all of their statutory
obligations
this is self-build plot for a family
with a long history in the village and
the cost and stress the process and this
uncertainty has been and indeed remains
considerable even though North Enders
attached before locals service village
meaning that it has deemed a sustainable
location for residential development the
case officer is recommending refusal and
the parish council agree as they
consider the site to be outside of the
village and therefore contrary to policy
CS 15 however the entirety of the
application site is within the north
ends to find built-up area boundary
notwithstanding the above a recent
appeal decision in North End for three
units clearly shows that sites located
to the edge of sustainable settlements
are acceptable even if they are outside
the village if there is a clear physical
and functional relationship between them
and the village the proposed wailing
continues an existing line of housing it
therefore is not an open countryside a
physical relationship to the village
additionally it is within walking
distance of village facilities and
therefore has a functional relationship
we consider this site to be a
sustainable location for this dwelling
the parish council has also objected on
the grounds that the scheme will have a
negative impact on the immunity of the
occupants of number 18 through
overshadowing lots of light and loss of
privacy we in the case officer disagree
the officer's report does not object to
the design site or location of the
dwelling within the plot with the
officer stating that posting has taken
cues from design characteristics of the
surrounding dwellings provide sufficient
immunity space who meets parfume
standards and that none of the proposed
windows contouring 3045 degree rule
which would result in the overlooking in
those loss of privacy the officer has
concluded that the dwelling is compliant
with the relevant sections of policy CS
5/32
CS noisiest world CS 26 and a s 10 this
plan compares the outline indicative
footprint with the proposed as you can
see the new training set slightly
further back with more space for parking
but with sufficient amenity space it is
actually only about 2 meters further
back than it was before in summary the
case officers recommendation for refusal
is based solely on his conclusion that
the site is not within the village and
there
not a sustainable location we arguing
that the defined who are blind
demonstrates that the site is within
North End and there is a clear physical
and functional relationship we hope that
this is straightforward to decision to
approve this thing I'm trying to do and
the officers design details all right
my colleagues thank you happy to answer
any questions okay do you have any
questions councillor Dixon just to make
it exactly clear of my own mind
obviously the outline Planning
Commission had an indicative plan yes
has what is being constructed or has you
said that reserved matters subsequent
application was put in and with a
different design same design because
obviously with indicative plans we both
know that it's not what's approved so um
basically the indicative plan was put in
just to show what was achievable on the
site it wasn't intended to be the
overall design the reserved matters
plans that were submitted admittedly
mistake ibly under the wrong mechanism
do match what has been built on side or
has been commenced on site and what we
are applying for now what was the from
the what was the feedback you received
it may have not been submitted in the
coordinate was it just a case of because
it's not been submitted in the right way
it was just thrown back at you back it
was validated it may be something that
might be better to come back to the
offices to clarify later if that's all
right if you're content as well I mean I
can answer that question I'm happy to
but I think I'll come back to the
officer so that what it sounds like is
this question of process rather than
nothing they're probably best place to
explain that to us any any further
questions from the committee
right in that case thank you both for
your time tonight right we now go to our
ward member counts the kettle
welcome counselor kettle I think you
know the routine you have five minutes
although you don't have to use all of it
and you can remain seated for any
questions at the end it wasn't to him to
talk over you Thank You mr. chairman
other this is a very unfortunate
situation which the report the design
access relates to a miscommunication I
would have a problem with that actually
our planning planning regulations are
quite simple and what what we have here
is we do have an application site which
regrettably is outside the physical
confines we and we now have a five-year
housing that supply and that's what
we've there's a major conflict which was
inadvertent and we've now got a property
which I think when I went look at it
over the fence was about eleven and
about twenty bricks high all the way
around so he says grossed a significant
distance and has clearly a huge amount
of investment has gone into it I have
had a number of conversations with the
agent who run me on more than one
occasion and I was not reading look at
look at the site and I've looked at
every different aspect
the only issue which I disagree with the
officer's report is is over looking over
bearing impact on number eighteen and
one of the things that came out is that
if you look at the plan as submitted
this application
the southwestern wall lines up with the
back of number 18 the neighboring
property on site that isn't accurate and
the agent explained that this the
Ordnance Survey map was inaccurate at
this point and that was my understanding
on the telephone conversation anyway but
there is a three meter extension beyond
the back wall of the neighboring
property so that you have a long line of
properties coming up at that street and
then you get this one here you can see
in that picture Thank You Matthew an
extension coming quite a long way back
so I've tried to work out how this
unclear this is this we're only looking
at one application an awful lot of works
gone and a lot of money's been spent on
it but as to whether one way of
mitigating the overlooking the
overbearing impact of number 18 was
whilst we keep the footprint as it is
and this is not Fugit aside I fully
accept and that the back end could be
made into it let's say one story element
and I suggested the applicant dish
withdraw and submit an application that
would therefore have lower impact on the
neighbor without actually disrupting on
the ground work they've already done and
I think that's the best way to go
forward but it's not the application
we're looking at it is a substantial
property Northend has had a series of
quite significant properties built over
the past four or five years or during
the course strategy period and this is
yet another one so I if it was something
that fitted in it's a number 18 and a
number on the other properties came down
because it's it's so much higher on the
hill and because it extends so far back
three meters may not be very much but it
is if you're living in number eighteen
there is there is more of an overbearing
impact than I think Matthew has
suggested in this case so I've got a
problem with it
clearly you know that a lot of work has
gone into it and it'd be great to see
this going forward into some sort of
approved property I just think what is
put what is
she's been built is so much bigger than
the outline drawing submitted to the
inspector and the impact on the neighbor
is something where it's a bit tricky and
therefore mine I would go back to my
what I want to suggest was that the
Advocate was to withdraw it and put a
new design in it does fit in and I think
that would that it would enable this
committee to approve as a subsequent
saige an application that was clutch
more compliant and have less impact on
the village and that is something I feel
very comfortable with but as it is it's
quite sizable property and as matthew
has pointed out it does sit outside the
physical confines and we have to accept
progressively that the inspectors
approval has lapsed and we has been no
subsequent application since that
application was lapse other than this
one in 30 seconds so it's really really
tricky I would like to support it but I
just think it is too big on the site and
we've already refused or East area
planning committee has refused an
application in this village we're on our
pill property had an overbearing impact
and therefore I'll go back to the hate
and family and say can we have something
which fits footprint which is like this
Mahler Thank You counsel
questions can't search it's just so
absolutely I think the message I'm
getting is that despite the fact the
outline is now lapsed the principle of
determine on this site your comfort
floor whether it's the scale and design
of it and it's so in terms of its layout
that you have an issue with today is
that right well no I mean I think we
have to accept that the application has
lapsed and that therefore Matthews
comments in his report where I differ
from his report as he's making a
balanced judgment between the fact there
is no application it sits outside the
current boundary but he says there is
not an overbearing impact I I tend to go
towards what the first counsel is saying
you said there isn't over
but but that could be mitigated by a
more sensitive subsequent application so
I have to accept when that would come
forward clearly we would have still had
the problem that it would sit outside
the confines but if it was one which was
less overbearing on the other properties
I would be much more inclined to go
against the fact the officer would that
again report it sits outside the
confines and I'd say actually because
the overbearing impact on the other
property will be it will be less one
would hope it would be less I would be
more comfortable with something which
was smaller cats are bonds my question
sort of been answered what you're saying
is because they've started on the
building but the wrong building in quite
badly for them to rebuild and
appropriate house it would be content
contrary to our policy on being rabies
but we do build outside be obese from
time to time so I would not have a major
problem with that as an issue my issue
is in supporting ops opposition I think
it's been rehearsed I think we've got it
now that a second Thank You councillor
do we have any other questions all right
councillor kettle thank you very much
for your time as well tonight thank you
right points for clarification any ideas
any questions can the officers shows the
indicative drawings etc admittedly it
may have lapsed it may have not be
extant but let's see exactly what was
approved originally thanks yeah so
what's up on screen in front of you is
what was submitted for the outline
planning application that was what was
considered by officers before and what
was refusing subsequently granted at
Appeal it's probably worth noting that
in the inspectors decision we're making
his final condition conditions he did
condition that plan as one of the
approved plans so there is some debate
whether or not the this out plans that
are now submitted were recorded with the
plan approved at that online stage okay
councillor Richards thank you can you
talk a little bit more about the
reserved matters application to come in
and just so we've got absolute clarity
on what happened and why simply put the
outline permission required the
applicant to submit a reserved matters
they didn't they submitted various plans
under discharge of conditions
application and that included some
details of a house in detail but those
did not satisfy the conditions of the
outline which required a reserved
matters application to be made that has
never been submitted or considered in
addition as Matthew pointed out this
plan was conditioned as part of the
outline the plans submitted as part of
discharge of condition don't comply with
that so even had they been considered as
a reserved matters application there was
no certainty that this Authority would
have approved them so in that sense it
is a lapsed permission it has not been
implemented and it has not formed a
fallback position for the consideration
of this application this application
should be considered on its merits and
they'll points of clarification and
other questions
all right we go to the debate go get
Richard go Thank You Jer so it's a very
unfortunate position we find ourselves
in I think the the ward members made the
position quite clear that whilst an
outline had been approved through appeal
we just heard from mobsters the layout
of that outline was very clear in and
set I suppose by the by the plan
Inspectorate we're looking at something
very different and it does have clearly
a material impact on neighbors it's
unfortunate that it's got to where it is
but the fact is we have a policy we have
policy sets out is a legal framework
that we have to abide by and this is
outside of that legal framework is not
it doesn't meet the required policies so
unfortunately I think I am going to have
to propose that we do refuse but I would
welcome seeing a new application coming
back that's in line with the original
approves that line one
yes fair enough Carol Dixon linkout
Saban's I would basically fully support
that that concept of a refusal of this
one but hopefully something else
more acceptable be coming forward we're
so seconding or I thought it was okay
Thank You sirs proposal second council
bonds to joint work this may be slightly
outside the scope the debate in the
notes it refers to in the event of this
being refused that enforcement action
will be considered and I think we can
appreciate what that would mean in the
grand scheme of things if the view is
that we are discussing
considering a future application how how
likely is it would we say that the that
enforcement will be implemented in the
short term as we're doing cause probably
going away from I think members have
already indicated that they'd like to
see another application but I don't
think this is the place to talk about
that what that would be although I
understand what you're saying we'll have
to leave that for another day I think
council Jennings I think have only the
neighbors actually objected here and not
quite I was trying to find page 51
lesser objection doesn't say if it's the
neighbors I'm afraid that's just one
letter of objection page 52 natee to
seek clarification before you move much
further the the recommendation in the
report is that this application be
refused because it falls outside the
physical confines of the bit village if
members were to issue a refusal on that
basis that would be an in-principle
objection to a dwelling in this location
on the basis that we currently do have a
five-year housing land supply we are not
therefore under similar position as the
inspector was when he considered the
application last time and granted it
yes we found ourselves in a position
where we have approved buildings outside
the belt very boundaries before I
[Music]
wouldn't want to put the applicant in a
position where we've set that precedent
set print and in principle refusal on
that basis here and that's largely
because of the manner in which the
outline and the reserved matters have
ended up proceeding in the way they have
wasn't very clear was it I think I
wouldn't want to preclude the
opportunity for another application to
come forward and have an automatic in
principle refusal on the basis of US
attorneys down today I think the
important thing for me is the
overbearing nature and the overlooking
of the neighboring properties rather
than the fact that it's in the building
outside the built area boundary I mean
he's on the very fringe of other
properties so I can't see why you can't
organically grow a village even if the
red line is just inside there and well
so what you're saying David yeah in
principle you have said well we're not
happy with it it doesn't preclude the
applicant coming back with another
application and it doesn't preclude us
coming to a different judgment at that
point does it there is the authority to
remain consistent with its decision
making so if members where this
committee to conclude that this is
outside the physical confines of the
village when the applicant returned to
us with an amended proposal we would
still have to conclude that it's outside
the physical confines of the village and
there would have to therefore be other
reasons for us to approve it as I set
out before and I sort of understand
where members are coming from with this
feeling that there has been a permission
granted that permission was granted to
sometime ago in very different
circumstances we have now a five year
having land supply we have a different
set of policies in force the application
needs to be determined on its merits in
officers view and you know the officers
assessment on societies that this falls
outside the physical confines of the VIN
members are at liberty to take an
alternative view but they do have to
take a view on that particular point I
would suggest do you have what two
things one is do you have a red line in
the BU a be available for us to look at
and secondly could if it's on can
indicate with the properties that yes so
the the application starts indicated by
the red dot obviously this was produced
by our policy team on the on the basis
that there was an outline Commission on
the site I see some of that work was
deaths and there is a slab base on the
side so that's so this is this is our
approved built-up area boundary this is
a draft yeah so we haven't approved one
and so we haven't gotten approval to
bury boundary this is an emerging
built-up area boundary that is still
draft and has been drawn on the basis of
an understanding of what planning
permissions are extant at the time it
was drawn it was assumed that the
permission had been you could you zoom
in a bit on the red dot please three
buildings just to yeah those outer
electron you did say that earlier sorry
while we're looking at that counselor
bonds you also had a question what
you're gonna speak the reasonable
refusal is very sad sad the village
boundary unconcerned I'm refusing we've
agreed that they can have a house there
it is smaller so I would have thought
the appropriate reason for refusal was
the size bulk and mass of this property
which would therefore mean that they
could still build where they have
started to build and come back with a
smaller application which didn't come to
committee but as far as I'm concerned to
give the reasons for refusal that we've
got here in appropriate for the
situation do you understand it's not
what you meant as well councillor dick
so will you also of that mind when you
proposed that we where will you go with
that we were you Jewish your concern
purely to do with the fact that it it
was inside or outside bill to bury about
or were you also concerned with the size
Balkan mass and development I was
specifically interested in understanding
exactly what had originally been agreed
ie and obviously indicative proposals
basically mean until you actually bring
something forward you know you can have
an indicative one that's three story
signs and we said well again without in
that etc and but it was really the
principle but having haven't seen this
then perhaps the reason for refuses
tonight is overbearing and mass etcetera
I think just to be clear I think we need
to give a reason this is China
why are we accepting this in principle
just so it doesn't come back to haunt us
so we confirm that basically this is
within the confines we're not accepting
principle you want to be clear on our
reason for a fuse laughing no because
basically we don't want to accept this
reason so we need to give a reason as to
why we accept that it can be it can be
built in this in this area but then we
need to give our reason of refusal as
well so basically giving two reasons
want to accept that in principle and one
to actually refuse carriages so before I
address that bit is there a reason why
I'm sure there is but I remember why
those out Hajj buildings aren't in or
can't be included as part of the
built-up area boundary because as far as
I'm going to end there building is built
up therefore should be part of it goes
back to the old assessment of how we
define our bill severe boundaries so
there's a list of types of uses that we
decide our inside and which our outside
for our assessment agricultural barns
are outside I thought I thought I might
be on so I just wanted to parent so my
thoughts on why this reason for a
feudalism right is that the built-up
area boundary 2017 emerging billsborough
boundary 2:17 clearly identifies this
site as within the built of very
boundary and I accept that
but in this instance for this proposal
the size bulk and overlooking
overbearing nature of the development
would be inappropriate and therefore
should be refused on that basis
are you satisfied earlier but basically
you still got to give a reason why in
order to accepting the reason for
forward by did so presumably because who
you're satisfied that this at site
actually would be in yeah only based on
my note it down a reason then for if I'm
gonna come to a reason for refuse
learners based on the design at the
building that is before us effectively
sighs etc so councillor Dixon you can
tend to continue to propose that thank
you
obviously you're happy with that right
if we're all happy to go all that we go
to the vote so the recommendation is to
refuse for the different reasons Mesa
yet actually changed my mind on number
one the wording I noted here for the
disagreement with the recommendation
recommended reason is that councillors
accept that the emerging bill turf area
boundary identifies this site within the
built-up area boundary and that they
accept that it is within the physical
confines of the village based on their
own assessment of the site and the
relevant information relating to build a
barrier boundary and the reason for
refusal is reason for refusal is that
the design size and position of the
proposed dwelling would result in an
overbearing impact on the neighbor in a
blown and with respect to their immunity
thank you
will contend to get to the vote all
those it so the recommendation then is
to refuse for all the reasons stated all
those in favor that we show
four or five sit Oh unanimous German
thank you Katie therefore resolves to
refuse application reference 19 / 0 1 2
1 6 / ful this is our last item
there's no urgent business therefore
meeting closed thank you very much
everybody